[INAUDIBLE]
CENNYDD BOWLES: And we have
a couple of folks coming up.
We have Karen?
KAREN KAUSHANSKY: Yes.
CENNYDD BOWLES: OK, fantastic--
and Josh?
Here, he comes.
OK, excellent.
So Kenneth, we just heard
from, so I won't introduce him.
Karen, I will--
oh, Sarah, sorry.
Yes.
No, please, sorry.
No, no, no.
Sorry, I almost let
you off the hook.
So Sarah and Kenneth, you've
just heard from today,
so I won't introduce
them, necessarily.
But Karen, I will attempt
an introduction of--
a local I believe
[? Basel-- ?] and many,
many years history working
in some of these making some
of the speculative futures--
real wearables, robotics,
voice interactions--
KAREN KAUSHANSKY: It's
interactions starting back
in 1996, so it's been
a long, long road.
This is the year of speech, I've
heard that about seven times
over the past 20 years.
CENNYDD BOWLES:
And Josh Lovejoy,
a colleague of mine
from Google, has
worked on many of
the projects that
were showed by
Jeremiah very early
on this morning,
particularly Google
Clips, the small robotic camera,
which I'm sure you might talk
about a little bit in reference
to what you're talking about.
We're now working a lot
on the PAIR initiative
and issues of bias and fairness
in learning systems and machine
learning systems.
Would you like to say anything
more to introduce yourself?
OK.
So first of all, I wanted
to kind of throw it
to Karen and Josh, a little
bit unfairly perhaps--
but as people who have
not been speaking today,
been in the audience--
maybe just two minutes
each on threads
that you've sort of seen
emerge through the day.
I've notes of my
own, but I'd love
to hear what your reflections
are on some of the talks
you've heard today and what
was sort of resonated with you.
KAREN KAUSHANSKY: Oh yeah,
thanks for having me.
And I always love
coming to these.
You just pick up
these nuggets, so you
don't expect to be eye opening.
And so, I think that a lot
of the thread, that even Alex
kind of summed up, is a lot of
the design is in the writing,
and we saw that with
Simone, and we saw that--
but if it was just so
easy to take a black box
and explain how things got into
the box, our job would be done.
It's not that easy,
because once you
start describing or explaining
with only a confidence of 43%,
then somebody looks at that
and says, well, that's shit.
Like, why am I going to use
that if it's 43% confident?
And so, how do we--
so two big things.
One is how do we get
people to play along
when the confidence
is low, and we're
talking about this at lunch.
Maybe it's like the eye
doctor a little bit.
Like, is it better like this,
or is it better like this?
Like, how do we get people to
play along and participate?
And I think a big thing
that I haven't heard today,
which is always what I-- a lot
of what I try to design for is,
like, how do we know
what we don't know,
and how do we explain
that in a way--
of the things that
we don't know--
it's like the why and why not.
Like, this is what I know,
but this is what I don't know.
And how do we design for that?
JOSH LOVEJOY: Yeah, a
lot of [INAUDIBLE] voice
is the future.
A lot of threads--
a couple of things
that spring to mind.
One of them is just
the fundamental need
for more just
dialectical discourse.
So much today was about
inspecting, and turning over,
and turning over again from
different perspectives.
And so, I just think
one of the aspects
that I really believe deeply
in, as a designer in this space,
is the need to kind
of take a page out
of the, kind of, social
systems thinking and especially
perspective taking.
The process of coming to
recognize the privilege
that one has in any
environment requires
stepping out of
your own experience
and stepping into the
lived experience of others.
Oftentimes, there's just
this huge disconnect
between the work that
we do as technologists
and the actual impact directly
on the human beings who
are affected by
it, or consume it,
and, in every instance, the ones
who train it which is, like,
totally anonymised people.
And sort of the way the other
thread that I've seen today
is a lot about the word
perfect or accurate.
I bristle a little bit when I
hear perfection or precision
talked about, because
there's almost
this underlying assumption
that future states can always
be predicted based
on past states,
and the reality that everyone,
I think, is pretty well aware of
is that most often the past was
not representative of the just,
you know, egalitarian
future that we want.
So because machine learning
can't predict a future state
that has no
precedent, how do you
build a prediction
model that actually
accounts for that complete lack
of the asymptotic sort of goal?
So it's like unless
there is something that--
like a state-- a
past historic state
that you're comfortable
with persisting forever,
then there's no such thing
as perfect or accurate--
so just like things to question.
CENNYDD BOWLES: So the
title of our panel,
if I can pronounce it, is
Opportunities and Challenges
for the UX of AI.
And one challenge I think-- a
thread that's come up for me
through the day and Kenneth
sort of put a nice hat on it
at the end-- is kind of the
challenge of people who are
involved in--
and the lady who just asked
a question as well, I think--
kind of talked about--
a little bit is the challenge,
for people making product
decisions, to
imagine or concretize
those decisions ahead of time
at the appropriate scales.
And I think one of the--
actually, when last year I
was originally talking
about this event,
we were talking about
scale and talking
about the different scales
that these things happen at
and the scale of the hypernudge
system that Kenneth was talking
about is something,
which, you know,
we can all recognize
that we're in now,
but we can't sort of
see the edges of it.
We can't sort of concretize
it, and I sort of--
I wanted each one of
you to reflect perhaps
on that thread of how do
designers working in concert
with engineers, and product
managers, et cetera start to--
helpfully, and then
time scales that
work in terms of
making products start
to sketch these scales
and these scales
of these dynamic
systems for each other,
as well as the eventual--
I don't like using
the term users--
but the humans involved
in each of these places
in these systems.
Let's come back to
Sarah on this one.
SARAH GOLD: So I can talk
to you specifically what
we do at F, as we went away
for retreat week the other week
to discuss what other
kinds of design we do.
Can we give them names?
And one of the things
we came up with was
service diagrams, which
might mean something very
specific to you, but
what we talk about
is when we are
designing anything,
we try to think about
how that service will
fit in a wider system.
So what else
happens around that.
An example might be if you're
designing, say, a new ticket
system for TFL, you don't
have to draw sort of TFL.
And then outside of
that, what does the law
say about ticketing?
And then you might have to draw
maybe someone getting cash out
of their local ATM.
Or it all depends on what the
thing is you're trying to do.
But it's about drawing all the
other entities around that,
and especially thinking
about regulation,
thinking about also adversarial
access in that system too
and what could go wrong.
And I think for us, it's a
really helpful way of thinking
about different
scales, because it
forces some of the
discussions out from something
that might be a very small
interaction that you're
discovering into something
that speaks much more
broadly about what
that decision means
for other individuals and
other institutions that
are a part of that service
in one way or another.
So that's certainly a
technique that we use.
And I think it's
quite an easy one.
You should give it a go.
JOSH LOVEJOY: A
couple of things, one,
I try to say that I
think the burden of proof
for whether or not something
should be automatable at all is
on the level of
agreement between people
about what good looks like, and
how robust that agreement is
to the diversity of
the people involved
and diversity of
the context of use.
So it's just flipping
the default assumption
that automation is good to
automation needs to be proven.
The second-- and this
is one that I recently
read a definition of
disability by the World Health
Organization, which
describes it as being
a mismatch between the
features of an individual
and the features
of an environment.
And I think talking about
that, we're all disabled.
We all have disabilities.
There are some more
persistent or more transient.
But that is a starting space
for innovation thinking.
I think, is just
really profound.
Very frequently, we begin
the innovation discussion
around the perfect alignments
between people and environment.
And we're like, oh sweet.
We can send them a notification.
And so I just look at it as
a provocation to the room.
I think that that's a
really concrete place
that I like to nudge
teams at Google towards.
And then the third is just
anything around this notion
of augmentation.
The most frequent question I
get asked by teams at Google
is why doesn't anybody
trust the recommendations
that my system is building?
Whether it's from
here's a fitness program
you should go on, or here's
a thing you should go do,
or a flight you should take or
whatever, and every one of them
starts with again,
this assumption
that there's a great
answer that can be vended.
And so there's a
little bit of a we'll
go back and walk in the
shoes of the individual who,
prior to this point, has
been making these decisions
confidently for themselves.
They're accountable
to themselves.
And there's a sense of pride
and craft and authorship.
So in that spectrum
of what it means
to feel like you've
made something,
there's a big space for--
you can modify something and
still feel like you made it.
You can pick out
from a selection
and still feel like you made it.
You can actually
hand craft things.
But again, we tend to
jump into this spot
where you can automate
the perfect thing.
And at that point, you've
taken away authorship.
You've taken away craft.
You've taken away the
personal expressions.
So how do you start in that
bigger space of a place
where somebody feels
like they can attach
their own personal touch?
AUDIENCE: That seems to resonate
with what Kenneth was saying
about the veil of ignorance
that John rules conception,
being able to place
yourself in an actor network
rather than being the designer
of a user centered design.
And I think one of the threads
that I was picking up on today
is do we come here to bury user
centered design rather than
praise it?
Is one of the opportunities
and challenges of the UX of AI
is that there's no
U there any more?
There shouldn't be.
And what I've heard
through the presentations--
this kind of thread of
thinking differently about--
or ditching the idea of a user.
I love to hear you
thoughts on that.
CENNYDD BOWLES: I'd
like to chip in on that.
Thomas Whent is a
designer in New York City.
He gave a great presentation
at Interaction '17.
I think it was called The
Critique of User Sense Design.
And he pointed out
a couple of things,
but one I'll focus on here.
UCD has, for better
or for worse,
often for worse,
focused relentlessly
on individual success and
individual productivity.
And Whent pointed
out that it hasn't
taken into account the
well-being of ecologies,
communities, democracies,
societies, et cetera.
So I think that's
certainly something
we've lost sight of
with that UCD focus.
UCD, for me, runs
into some challenges
when we are talking about
devices that live with us.
Because the question then,
as you point out Matt,
isn't really about how do
we use these technologies,
but how do we cohabit with them?
How do we share an environment
with them healthily?
And also, if I
may, I'm just going
to rewind to the
previous question
as well, because I have a
little thought about scale.
For me, scale is less
useful to have processes.
Processes, I think, don't
scale as well as cultures.
So I'm more interested
in bringing humans
at the heart of this work
through cultural work.
And I'm also interested
in looking at the default
ideologies of the
tech community,
because that really is what
sets our culture, which in turn,
begets process, et cetera.
And I want to have
a minor rant about
the predominant
ideologies in tech
right now, which are lean
startup and the Californian
ideology.
A lean startup is
a system that's
predicated upon empiricism.
The fact is offered that it's
futile to predict the future,
therefore we should be learning
exclusively through empiricism,
build measure, learn,
build, measure, learn.
There's no space for ethical
discourse within that system.
There's no space
for anticipation
of potential harm
within that system
until it's done, which I think
is something that has led us
down the wrong path, ethically.
And the California ideology--
I recognized I am in
Switzerland, but at Google
so there's an interesting
conflict there.
If you haven't read the
initial paper from '95,
it's Andy Cameron
and Richard Barbrook,
a kind of slightly weird
but excellent piece
about essentially the political
agendas of Silicon Valley.
And it's still the case.
And without getting
overly political,
I don't think it's
necessarily a model that
will help us become
more ethical and create
better human-centered
technologies
in the next decade.
So when I hear London,
Berlin, et cetera,
saying how do we capture some
of that Silicon Valley spirit,
my response is always don't.
We don't need more of it.
We need something more local.
We need something different
to change the pattern,
to change the trajectory
that we're on.
KAREN KAUSHANSKY: To
the scale question,
I think as a designer who's
working on a day to day basis,
before we get to
scale, let's just
kind of make better
what we have today.
And some of that is I
think, identifying the seams
so we can make beautiful seams.
And we can show those seams.
And so it's a lot
about identifying
every step of the way,
kind of what can go wrong.
And that can be pretty tedious.
I think it goes back
to what Sarah, what you
were saying about the service
design, and just identification
of all the different flows
and all the different ways
that things can go.
Chris Nestle, who wrote
"Identative Design"
and "Make It So," he walked
us through this future's wheel
exercise, which has you put
down kind of a prediction.
And then from that
prediction, you
write out direct consequences
of that prediction.
And then for each
consequence, you
write other direct consequences
of the consequences.
And then you link up
indirect consequences.
And you're going
to find the seams.
What happens when this
indirect consequence
and this indirect
consequence happens together?
And you're like, whoa.
That's kind of maybe where
the future is going to go
and we didn't even realize it.
So that's been a helpful tool.
CENNYDD BOWLES: So can I bring
you back to burying the U in UX
and your opinions of that?
Just means I'll be
in a job correcting
of stationary and
lanyards and slide decks,
if we get to cross the U off.
SARAH GOLD: I don't know
what to think about that.
I know that I'm
designing for somebody.
I'm designing for a need.
I'm designing something
that I want somebody
to use that hopefully
in some cases
will make their lives better.
I was hoping to design
autonomous vehicles.
So everything that
Dan was talking about,
bigger cities, better cities.
My user is the reason
I'm doing this so.
I have a hard time
saying we've given up.
It should maybe be expanded,
cities, democracies,
political agendas,
things like that.
But I can't let go of my user.
JOSH LOVEJOY: Yeah,
I would agree.
When I hear arguments
against user-centered design,
often what I feel
like I'm hearing
are arguments against the
current optimization strategies
that are way overblown
in UCD, particularly
things like engagement through
clicks, or time on task,
or conversion, and
things like that.
And to go back to
your point, Kenneth,
I think the prevailing
conventional wisdom
is get to market,
and then all else
will follow kind of a thing.
And for the larger
companies, it's
our responsibility to actually
think in total polar opposite.
You can't actually
just say we're
going to push
something out there,
and then hopefully
more people come to it.
And then we'll fix the
problems as they arise.
Rather you have to actually
kind of do the due diligence
upfront, and think about a
broader spectrum of users.
The other aspect from a
machine learning perspective
is if you actually want to
build for a robust system that's
going to be iterative
and useful over time,
it's incumbent on you to look
at a really broad spectrum
and an intersectional
spectrum of user behavior.
So you have to think about
it from through to the end
application of technology,
therefore have a user.
It's just our traditional
user has kind of played out.
And it's not going to be useful
in modeling the effectiveness
of the system.
SARAH GOLD: So on
user-centered design,
I think that the concept of
an individual that you're
designing for is still
incredibly important.
And I have lots of views on how
and why we should also think
about large groups of people.
But something very
specific about AI
and user-centered
design is as soon
as you bring data
into your design,
which I think is really
important actually,
is how you think about scale is
also thinking about data flows
as well, as you think about
a kind of user journey.
What's the data that's
being collected?
How has it been collected?
This idea of where ownership
of that data might be.
But really, who has
rights to see it
is really important, because--
I'm trying to think of a
better way to describe it.
I'm just going to
go for it, which
is that if we continue to
design for an individual,
but the data that we are
fundamentally asking them
to give consent
for or to look at
is many people have rights over
it, we can't design for it.
So I think the
concept of a user need
breaks down when you
realize the material stuff
we're asking them or giving
them permission to do something
with isn't owned by them.
At the moment we have this
really strong story about I
own my data.
Well actually, there's not much
data that I do own, in fact.
And I would encourage
you all to look
at the Open Data Institute's
definition of kind of ownership
on this, because in
fact, data about me
is also data about my
sister or my mom or my dad.
Data about me in this room
is actually about all of us.
So there really is that kind of
collective right that we have.
And it's only
something I've just
thought about here, which is
that the user need is a very
difficult concept for me to
start thinking about broader
systems, because the material
stuff we're working with isn't
kind of owned by an individual.
We have to think about this
from the perspective of many.
AUDIENCE: I guess
coming back to something
that Josh and Fernando had
talking about as [INAUDIBLE]
your sponsor.
Is that kind of making a human
centered AI the easiest option?
And some of that goes to the
practitioners of this as well.
And so I think my call,
I guess, is can we
make it easier to
incorporate in the day
to day some of these multi-actor
networked collective ways
of looking at ways in
which people are engaging
with technology,
make that as easier
as it's become through
various scenes of training
and technology and
conference talks and tools
and all the rest of it, that
we've had over the last 15
years, as we've made or
as rigid as we've made
user-center design in a way?
Is there a way to
build our way out
of this in ways that give
very busy people the tools
to do so easily?
CENNYDD BOWLES: Yes.
And people will make a good
living over the next 5 to 10
years writing books about
those, giving talks about it,
doing training and saying,
here are some simple techniques
that you can use to increase the
view of stakeholders you have,
if you like broadening
the views of stakeholders
to include societies and
populations and so on.
Is that what we
actually want though?
It may be what we want.
Is that what we actually need?
Do we want to make these
techniques low in friction,
or do we want to
actually do them justice?
Maybe we need to push
back from the idea
that it has to be something
that subservient to the need
to deliver quickly.
Because maybe
that's the problem.
Maybe it's we find ourselves
in this mess because we
felt this deterministic pace of
change, this manifest destiny
that technology has to
go out there tomorrow.
Maybe that's what's got us in
this mess in the first place.
Maybe we need to step back
and address these issues
in a friction full way, rather
than a frictionless way.
JOSH LOVEJOY: I would
kind of add to that.
But that's kind of a pivot
from the statement of making it
the easiest is understanding
that once you've
seen some direct harm that's
been caused to a human being,
it's impossible to
look away from it.
And to the work, the two, three
years working on clips, trying
to figure out what like
an intelligence program
looks like to me
as a designer, I
realized that it was
really user research that
was the fundamental thing we've
been doing all along that we
need to come back to.
A UX researcher,
their primary job
and the day to day comings and
goings of the product design
is advocacy for human beings.
They are closest to them
in the ideation phase,
in the research phase.
They're closest to them
in the evaluation phase.
And it's this person that
we've delegated-- this role
that we've delegated
to be the advocate.
And they advocate
to product managers.
They advocate engineers.
The advocate to designers.
And the most successful
that a UX researcher can be
is in influencing the
decisions of others
who get to shape the
code or the metal that
goes out to a human being.
Everyone else is like an
indirection layer away,
farther away from them.
And it's striking that the
majority of the training
data that goes into
machine learning models
is super distant from
actual user advocacy.
The people who are
closest to it are the ones
that often don't have the
closest access to understanding
user need or human need.
It's distant from user research.
And there's no one advocating
for the protocol design
and the labeling process,
the data collection process,
the evaluation process.
And to call back
to the practical,
what can we do with the--
how do we make it the easiest?
I think we build on
the existing systems
we have with UX research.
And we expand that role to
encompass data collection
and protocol design and
evaluation so that we expand
advocacy, and we make
it harder to turn away
from the impact of the
decisions that we make.
Once you've seen that impact,
the easiest thing to do
is address the problem.
SARAH GOLD: I really agree
with what you're saying.
And I want to add that in
certain areas that if it's been
working, getting research though
into the places where data is
collected, particularly
say, in a medical context,
is so difficult. So it
just means that you are
in a situation where the
products you want to ship
haven't been fully tested
because you couldn't.
And the data, even if you
do develop dummy data,
it's never going to be as
rich as the real thing.
I think also thinking about
the kind of ethical procedure
of how we can get in
front of more people
and have access to the
right kinds of information
is really important to
make sure that we're
making the right thing to
say I've totally hear you.
And I think it's currently
the kind of ethical frameworks
we have around access to
information about individuals
to test products are
necessary and should be hard.
But that I don't think they're
aligned with the process
of making right now.
So it is very difficult
to get to that point.
KAREN KAUSHANSKY: Yeah.
Just back to the friction
point that was made.
So when the original
question was asked,
I actually thought about
it in the opposite.
I think what I heard
is it's OK to maybe put
in some friction in the process.
And then I just worry
that we're going
to bias this towards people
that are suckers for friction,
meaning they're willing to
take more time out of their day
to do two more steps.
So they're willing to
look under the hood.
And then the people who
aren't, well then, I
guess they're not going
to be part of this.
CENNYDD BOWLES: Like,
slow food is easy
if you're rich and
have lots of time.
KAREN KAUSHANSKY: Yeah, right.
So my first thought was
less work, more benefit.
I can use this
because it's so easy.
It's like implicit
data collection.
But look at the
benefit that I get.
And once I've come along with
that-- once I've said yeah,
I understand all the
benefits, I'm hooked,
then maybe you can introduce
some of that friction.
CENNYDD BOWLES: Josh, did
you want to comment on--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you guys
kind of got to my question.
Because I actually
wanted to revisit
this point about friction,
and essentially the cost of it
and who bears that cost?
Because I can see very
much a world where
we have organic free range
AI, which is totally unbiased
and has been thought
through all the way through,
and it comes to market later,
and you pay a premium for it.
And the other stuff
is essentially
becomes a tax on the poor.
So there is kind of a theory
right now that advertising
is becoming a tax
on the poor, people
who can't pay for it to
go away until we could
get in a similar situation.
On the other hand,
you could also
get into a place of who is this
person that does the extra two
steps each time?
Well, one is it's the
person who is rich and has
the time on her hands.
The other is that it's
actually passed down the chain.
And those people will do
it to essentially avoid
some advertising or get
a little bit more AI time
or whatever it is, while
the rich are essentially
paying for their labor,
or their subsidized labor.
So I just want to throw
out that really happy topic
to the group, and see if--
SARAH GOLD: Last week, or the
week before, I think the Web
1029 and Tim Berners Lee wrote
an article in "The Guardian."
And I can't the
life of me remember
the exact phrasing of it.
But a bit of it said
that we're stuck
in a place where we think that
advertising is the only way
to pay for digital services.
And we need a little
more creative thought.
And I thought that was so good.
Because I really believe that.
I really think there
are other models.
So there's a big economic
piece in there to discuss.
Just wanted to jump
in there with that.
CENNYDD BOWLES: I hear it's good
on panels to have disagreement.
So I will disagree.
I think the advertising use
cases is blamed unfairly
for ethical violations,
particularly
by a certain sort of
agitators and people
who denigrate certain
business models
for the benefits of their
alternative business models.
The truth is, data is
valuable to any business now.
There's nothing exclusive
about its advertising value.
In, fact its value is
increasingly centered
on its value as training data,
its analytics data and so on.
And the value to advertising is
actually not strictly relevant.
I think what we're seeing is--
and we can get very
political here very quickly--
but it's the natural outcomes
of a system that has always
essentially shafted
certain people
and rewarded certain people.
I'm always skeptical of calls
to abandon ad funded models,
because ad funded models have
brought free transformative
technologies to billions.
And I wouldn't want
to throw that away
to see a system that essentially
makes technology a luxury good
again.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
CENNYDD BOWLES: You
sponsored the thing.
Please--
AUDIENCE: I would love to ask a
question about explainable AI.
And I have a reason why.
So I have both a question
and I have a comment.
So my question is
for the entire panel,
how useful do you think
that explaining AI is?
And I'll qualify that question.
So that's where the comment is.
I think explainability is
super useful for practitioners
and for builders,
because basically
if you have explainability,
you can debug your system.
So that's a granted thing.
But for end users,
what I worry about is
that I feel like in
a room like this,
I think there's an assumption
that explainability
for end users is super useful.
And it's a desirable thing.
And I believe that.
I come from my data
visualization background.
And if I can visualize
the heck of your data
and show it to you as
a mirror of yourself,
I will be super happy.
Because I'm like, you're
going to be more informed.
You're going to be
making better decisions.
And I'm all for explainability.
Then I came to Google.
And I realized that end users,
most of the time, do not care.
And they look at transparency
about their history
of their data, and most
users never look at that.
And they don't care.
And so my question comes
from this point of view.
Is it people like
us who are assuming
that end users actually
want explainability?
And if so, why do they want it?
How is it useful?
And how do we make
them care, basically,
at the end of the day?
AUDIENCE: Because of a thread
I was going to pick up,
I'd like to throw into
that and see what happens.
It was a quote from Patrick's
talk, but also I think,
echoed through some of the
things we heard this morning.
And Patrick said, blurring the
line between writing and using
software.
So again, we're
back to the role--
what role do we have?
Are we end users, or do we
have authorship or agency?
And does that change the
demand for explicability
and these sorts of things.
For plus five difficulty.
CENNYDD BOWLES: Well, I don't
want to hog the mic, here.
I'm always worried
when I hear things
like how do we make people
care about something.
That strikes me as a
pretty loaded comment,
no offense meant.
Even if users don't
care, regulators will.
And I think there comes a point
at which it's simply good AI
hygiene to have
explainability baked in
or to have at least an approach
to it within your systems,
even if it's something
trivial, like should I
have chicken curry?
Yes, no?
Yes?
OK, great.
Tell me how.
We want to be sure
that certain systems--
essentially those systems
that have a strong impact
on human freedom such as
criminal justice, algorithms,
sentencing algorithms,
and so on, those
have to be explainable.
And I don't buy any of the sort
of hand-waving and question
dodging I hear sometimes from
data scientists and machine
learning specialists
saying but, deep learning--
we're eight layers deep.
We just simply cannot do that.
You find a way or don't
use those systems.
AUDIENCE: That's a very
active area of research.
As I was saying,
contextually speaking,
I think there are scenarios
and reasons why we
want explainable AI, for sure.
Criminal justice?
For sure.
But again, I think it's
very dangerous for us
as a community to be assuming
certain things that users
want these things.
And so I would challenge
us all to be thinking
about creative ways in which
these things can be actually
useful to users
instead of a you need
to eat your broccoli today.
It's going to be good for you.
So I'm curious about are
there creative ways--
because I feel like
that's one of the things
that designers do so well is
you engage with the messiness.
We engage with the realities
of the users and the user need.
So I'm curious what user need
are we actually talking about?
Granted, when things
in machine learning
go wrong, if you get the
wrong recommendation,
definitely you're going to want
an explanation, And absolutely.
But 99% of the rest of the
time, why do we need that?
KAREN KAUSHANSKY: That's
what I was going to say.
It was like they don't
care until they will care.
And they're going to care
when something goes wrong.
Again, it's almost like
knowing what you don't know.
How are we going to
know when we're wrong?
And do we just
explain everything?
But of course, you are going to
want a different lens of when
something is wrong,
when something is right,
and how you explain it.
So it goes back to almost
what I started saying before.
How do we know when we're wrong?
How do we know
what we don't know?
And maybe that's OK.
Just knowing to explain
it when things go wrong.
JOSH LOVEJOY: And
like, so many things
in this area, that
are like, well,
depends what you mean
by explainability.
Throughout the process of trying
to figure out the fairness
question at Google, and figure
out how to implement fairness
into the lifecycle,
into the launch process,
it always struck me as odd
that the starting point for all
this stuff was to figure
out some universal metric.
But whereas in human day
to day conversations, when
we want to try to get
an answer from somebody,
it's kind of a ludicrous
thing to ask somebody
why did you do that?
It's especially
ludicrous to ask a child.
And yet, I do it
every single time.
My six-year-old pushes my
3-year-old or something
like that.
Why did you do that?
He's going to make up a reason
is what's going to happen.
But what we do in
the more risky areas
is we perform some layer of
calibration and accreditation.
You have to take a
test to drive a car.
You have to pass a bar exam
if you want to be a lawyer.
There's systems.
To be a doctor, you
can't just show up
and think you have a good idea.
You have to be certified.
And so the sort of
interesting question
I think we have
as a community is
to talk about what it means for
something to be good enough.
Like a data set
to be good enough
or have enough sort of
quality or a thoroughness
or a representativeness
into it, so that we know
it's a credible source of data.
How would we then
take that and to know
that the model is
credible enough to operate
within a given context?
So I think that that ability
to track through from intent
into application, and to know
that the sources, the euros
collected, the people that
were involved in collecting it,
the underlying
assumptions that went
into the methodology
of collecting it-- it's
important for the people
who are the makers.
I think that's our first user.
To answer maybe one
or two questions--
our first user that
we need to hit--
just why we focus
on it with pair--
are the people who
are shipping code,
who have to look at
it, who have to wear
that iron ring so
to speak, and make
the decisions thoughtfully.
If they can look at
a data set and say
yeah, that's a representative
of the intended application
that I think I want
to train my model for,
then that's a lifecycle that
I think we can start out with.
And with that, comes
explainability I
think in a certain--
SARAH GOLD: I think there
are layers of users.
And I think that's
kind of where we
got to the previous
question-- that question
of what is the user need can
be so harmful to a project.
It can also be really
useful at the right time,
but can also kill work.
So I think it should be
used wisely as a question.
I think it's used
too widely, actually.
Because there are certainly
user needs of explainability
that are to do with
when things go wrong.
Absolutely.
And those go through
lots and lots
of different chains
of whether that
be an individual
in an organization,
or a parliamentary
committee, or there are so
many different levels of users
the we need different kinds
of explanations.
I think in general,
for a sort of end user,
so to speak, actually,
there's a lot
to be said about
the sort of folklore
that we tell ourselves about
the magic of technology
and how things
work, and the sort
of stories we end
up telling ourselves
because we just don't get it.
That will certainly continue.
But I think we have
a duty of care to try
and help people get this
stuff, because there's
a danger in that magic.
And I just always
think about individuals
that I've watched
who might be trying
to help set up an iPhone for
their elderly grandparent.
And wanting to take a lot of
care over that, because you're
making decisions on the
behalf of someone else.
And I think sometimes
that's where
you get to what the user
need to explainability is.
It's kind of so you can
make the right decisions.
And so you can be
in control of that.
And I think that often when you
talk about I don't care-- well,
think of all the times
you've helped your mom fix
a piece of technology, or
even helped your daughter
or son to make something work.
You need to have a level
of understanding and trust
in that you can make
decisions for other people.
It's a really important part
of being human, and building
trust and relationships.
So I think to forget that, is to
forget what humanity is about,
really.
I know it goes
really, really meta.
But that's what I believe.
JOSH LOVEJOY: Actually, it's
just another echo from Patrick,
from your presentation.
You talked about teaching as
being this process of trying
to piece back together the
process by which you attained
the knowledge in
the first place.
But the other person
you're trying to teach
doesn't have the
shared experiences.
And therein lies the magic and
the messiness to your point.
AUDIENCE: Just to
editorialize, the explanation
is an invitation.
It's an invitation to
others to make it better,
even if it hasn't gone wrong.
And I think that's a place
where the refuge of magic
as a metaphor for
technology design has--
I think that's
where it went wrong.
Is I think we should consider
magic harmful, like go-to
statements.
The explanation is
an invitation is
the thing that gives me hope for
where we might take this stuff.
I think Dan had a comment.
AUDIENCE: I think I knew
what I was going to say
when you asked the question.
But then Sarah said it's all
about the essence of humanity.
So I'm lost.
I wonder if-- and this is a
sort of a half formed thought--
that as designers, those of us
that grew up with the internet,
for a long time, user-centered
design things took root
because we were dealing
with a certain kind of thing
as our [? outpolled. ?]
The first 15 years,
20 years of the
internet or the web--
which I will say the
web to be specific--
we're dealing with a
certain type of material.
It was sort of the media,
or it was music industry,
or it was search results, or it
was advertising systems related
to that.
And I suppose where a few
of us have been going today
is that now those
systems are beginning
to embed but themselves in
the fabric of everyday life,
the really physical stuff.
It's different.
And it's different if it
runs your energy system.
It's different if it affects
whether the bus turns
up or not.
It's different whether you
get into the housing co-op.
And it's beginning
to, as we can see,
understood that it
actually maybe changes
national politics,
all kinds of things.
And it wasn't the
case some years ago.
Maybe it was, because it
was running under the radar.
We weren't explicitly
addressing that.
So UCD and the techniques we
have could for a long time
get by with a very
individualistic view.
And just to be
super clear, I once
designed the Spice
Girls website.
That's the kind of stuff
that the first 10, 15 years
was about.
Turns out, that's incredibly
important apparently
for the 14-year-old girls.
But it's now become
as it's embedded
into everyday
infrastructure, it's
raised the bar in the type
of design that we have to do.
So this explainability question
is now incredibly important.
Because I can see why people
weren't interested particularly
in Google Search data
for quite a long time.
But if it now affects the
way that my life actually
works in a very direct way,
really fundamental things
like whether food trucks turn up
or not, then that's different.
So it picks up your point
I think also about not just
user-centered design, but
a system-center design,
or a civic-center design.
Each of those two systems has
an impact well outside of that.
The explainability of a
bus stop is important.
That's why I put the planning
notice up there as well.
So really, that piece of paper
is a really ham fisted attempt
to explain that something is
going to happen in your stream.
This is the decision
making process around it.
Here's who's behind that.
And here's who the
arbiter of that,
as in the local government.
And here's where to go and
talk to someone about it.
So as Matt says, that's an
invitation to get involved,
or to figure out what that
is now for everything else.
AUDIENCE: I'm going to use your
opportunity to thank everyone
for sharing everything
you've shared
this morning and this afternoon.
I wonder if we are
blurring a lot of lines.
Because I don't think
we are questioning
the value of explainability.
I wonder if there are
different layers of UCD?
So is it that sometimes
a regulator is our user?
Or other times where the actual
end consumer is our user?
And so I wanted to hear your
thoughts on that, because I
feel like with a lot of
the transparency, openness
that we are asking
for, we are also
almost pushing the
responsibility or use
to the user.
And I don't think that is
fair, because the education
levels of our community are just
not at all in the same level.
Until we do a lot
of education reform,
we are not at that level.
So I don't think it's fair for
a large amount of the population
to ask people to be
vigilant about these things.
I don't want to get
into a supermarket
and feel afraid that the
ceiling is going to drop on me.
But there are laws and
policies and liability rules
that are protecting me.
So is it that we are
blurring the lines?
And we should think about
different layers of UCD?
And how to design for
those different levels?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm Rachel.
I run a think tank in London
called [INAUDIBLE] everyone.
We just did a piece of research
looking into people's feelings
and at an attitudes about tech.
And I think the really
important thing that
hasn't been touched
on is I can feel
20 different things at once.
I can not care at all, because
I have to do it quickly.
And I can simultaneously,
morally, and ethically
care deeply.
And I think that
that is glossed over.
And in terms of thinking about
how we regulate and how we
design for regulators, there's
a real issue around regulating
for things that
cannot be anticipated.
So everybody knows a
bridge is meant to stay up.
The problem is in anticipating
both the things that
are unlikely to go
wrong, and that actually
how can we understand
people's reactions to things
if we're presuming
they aren't interested?
And then it has to be easy.
And I think the
only thing I'd add
is that maybe not everybody
has the time to have everything
explained to them.
But who is in
charge of choosing?
And that it isn't a company.
It isn't an
[INAUDIBLE] designers.
There needs to be a democratic
accountability there
which is likely to be different
countries, unfortunately.
SARAH GOLD: The really
good example of that--
I just really want to stay
before it goes out of my head,
because it will--
on this retreat we were
at, we were in Valencia
for the Internet
Freedom Festival,
which is something I
try to go to every year.
And it's quite kind of
heartbreaking event actually.
And it's sort of getting more
and more dystopic every year
I go.
But this year there
was a talk that
was about abuse
towards women in India.
And I think it might
have been last year,
there were the horrific
stories of women
being attacked on buses.
And what happened to
that period of time
was there was suddenly a
flood of apps onto various app
stores for women to
say where they were
and that they were safe.
But many of those
apps were not secure.
They were sending data
directly to abusers
and to groups of attackers.
Now this is a real example
of [INAUDIBLE] comment
about I go into
supermarket and trust
that the roof won't fall down.
Is it the Google's Play Store--
is it their responsibility to
have then banned those apps?
How can regulation
keep pace with the fact
that within the
space of 24 hours,
there had been a flood
of apps on the market
that then women had
downloaded and started to use?
So there's a real question here
about sort of transparency.
And as I mentioned before,
the kind of course correction.
And where can we help people
to make better decisions?
Because it's a really,
really hard issue to solve.
But it's super
important because it's
affecting individuals who are
less privileged in a really
serious way every day.
So it definitely can't be us.
I completely agree.
[INAUDIBLE]
JOSH LOVEJOY: Well,
one just small note,
interesting to note--
and it's not perfect--
but of all of the different fake
news and weird filter bubbly
conversations--
Wikipedia has been left
pretty much intact.
It's an interesting
case study to look at.
I feel at the risk
of saying something
I'm probably not supposed
to say, the excuse of 400
million hours of videos
uploaded to YouTube every hour
or whatever--
so it's just there's
too much to wrangle.
I think we can probably
do better than just
saying there's too much.
So there's a question of
how you actually take maybe
some pages out of the
leaning into dialogue
and leaning into ways that
people can actually do some
self-regulation.
There's always going
to be a power dynamic
or a power law of
not everyone is going
to want to deeply introspect.
But there is a trust and the
fundamental good of a system
that someone
hopefully has thought
about the structural
integrity of a system.
And I think it can't
just be companies.
And it can't just be regulators.
And it can't always
be the individual.
So just some food for thought.
AUDIENCE: Hi, everyone.
I just wanted to build on some
of those things that were said,
or talk about a particular thing
that I was interested to see
what your reaction was.
I think we've all been talking
about design and technology
and progression.
And we're all kind of
the developers of that.
And that is opportunistic.
And in the way that we
create those opportunities,
we become responsible for them.
So it kind of fills
in the discussions
that have gone on that we are
responsible as the developers
and the creators.
And I think that what I
was wanting to discuss
was there seems to be a kind of
time lapse issue where you've
got the creators
and the developers,
people inside companies.
It's not the companies
are, but it's
the people inside
the companies are
developing these opportunities.
And then there's a
kind of time lapse.
And then there's other
people that then take up
these opportunities that could
be political opportunists,
as we've seen last week.
I think you are describing
that as a perverse distortion.
Yes.
So you've got that, which I
think is a kind of a time lag,
is a second wave.
And then you've got a
kind of final wave, which
has to do with legals and
legislation, which is always
behind.
And it was very interesting
listening to Alex's talk
about taking up the
kind of position
of trying to validate
and certify the things
that she was interested
in, in the first wave.
So a kind of community
of first wavers
taking up a position of
responsibility for things
that they're creating.
And I thought that
was interesting.
But I'd like to just ask what do
you think about this time lag?
And how does it work?
Because it's gone wrong.
JOSH LOVEJOY: One
quick anecdote on that.
So there was an article recently
in the "Washington Post"
after we shipped Google
Clips, that was something
to the effect of Google hasn't
built an all seeing eye yet,
because you've got to
have a click bait title.
But the general provocation
or the conceit of the article
was to try to see if
the camera was racist.
Everyone in our group was
high fiving each other, not
because of the result of that,
but because the article was
written.
Because we designed
that product so that
that article could get written.
It took a three or
four year out-view
where we basically were at the
outset of thinking about how
to design the product.
We basically were tasked
with collectively thinking
about the worst
possible applications
of commoditizable
surveillance technology,
and how it could be used,
in particular, to be
harmful to people who were in
more sensitive places in life.
And I'll just say
one of the personas
that we used to drive
all of our ideation--
there were many--
but one of them
was think through
the individual who
might be going to transition who
has told some of their people
in their life, and
not everyone else.
How would you avoid
unintentionally
outing that individual?
So that's an example
of some of the stuff
that we thought about.
That just stuff was pervasive.
So I as the team grew from--
Jess was maybe the fifth or
sixth person on the team,
as it grew to a
couple of hundred--
every single person got that
core question asked to them.
And it's not like there's a
waterfall or a snowball effect
that goes into that.
So that by the time three
or four years rolled around,
the answer was no, we hadn't
built a racist camera.
It was the coolest adversarial--
like, yeah!
Someone tried to break our
thing because we wanted it.
CENNYDD BOWLES: I was just
going to comment quickly.
Eric Martin [INAUDIBLE]
wrote a book called
"Design For Real Life."
And one of the techniques
they talk about there
is the idea for designated
descent, which is sort of maybe
slightly similar to this
constructive antagonism
position within a team.
And that sounds like
a great example.
The idea of this
time lag is true.
It exists.
But it's still our problem.
We still have to deal with it.
We're now getting a
better understanding
of how the trajectory
of technology
tends to evolve over four
five years of its life,
when we recognize the
limitations of just focusing
on that initial
early adopt use case.
But all of those consequences,
they're not necessarily
directly anticipatible,
but they are
within the realm of
possibility, and as such,
are something we should look at.
So the designated
decenter are questions
like that for the clips product,
goes some way to stepping
in that direction I think.
KAREN KAUSHANSKY: And
I'll just say there's
been a couple of articles--
I think even this past
week-- about data scientists
and designers working together.
And I think if we
work together more,
we'll bring in
those time lapses.
I think it is understanding
it is collaborative.
It's a whole team
working together
to bring something to market.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So I've heard the R word
thrown around a few times.
That's regulation, in
the context of a GDPR.
But this is not going to be
the first wave of the internet,
where aside from a little
bit of legislation,
intermediary liability, you
could grow a nice big internet
company and be left alone.
Regulators are gunning
for AI, both in a positive
and a negative sense.
Because of course, there's
also a lot of positive change
that has to happen.
If you want
self-driving cars, you
have change the
road regulations.
But because of the worries.
And so the EU is
going to come out
with a big AI strategy
next month, which
will include them
developing initially
soft loss of voluntary
guidelines for ethics,
sometime in the autumn.
The Council of
Europe, which also
includes Russia and Turkey, and
God forbid, even Switzerland--
Well, that's again,
up to the same people
who decided on Brexit.
Because it's the European
Court of Human Rights
is the council of Europe.
So if they want to get
out of the jurisdiction
of the European Court
of Human Rights.
But so anyways, they're
also developing guidelines.
There's an expert group
that has [INAUDIBLE]
and Karen Young in it that will
produce something by next year.
So you're going to start
seeing these initially soft law
guidelines, but they
could become a hard law
on some of the ethical and
human rights aspects of AI.
I want to ask you all what
those should look like,
because that's a whole
different day of discussion.
And you know a lot of
the ideas out there.
Are there any really
bad ideas out there?
In addition to
all the good ideas
that policy makers
want to act on,
is there a do no harm
principle where we should not
touch something as policy makers
that you would sort of warn us
off from?
SARAH GOLD: Probably a lot.
I can speak to that 3D example
of the cookie law, which
was awful, and it has made even
worse with the e-privacy law.
I won't even try and explain
the history of the cookie law.
But it's a bad design patent.
No one really reads it.
It's really annoying.
Doesn't really help you
understand the thing
they're trying to
tell you to do.
But that then was
written into policy
that every website had
to have a cookie notice.
So this really
bad design pattern
then became regulation
across all websites.
And pretty much was oh, no.
Don't talk to me yet until
you've clicked my thing
and you've agreed that I can put
these cookies onto your laptop
with really weird interaction.
We recognize that cookie
law should probably never
have happened.
But the emphasis now
been on browsers.
So soon as you
install a browser,
you then have to go
through a whole cookie
kind of process of deciding
your permissions up
front there in browser.
And that also isn't really
solving the problem.
It's just putting the
problem elsewhere and making
a whole load of other problems.
So I think if there's one
thing I could say, is let's
not do that anymore.
As in, basically
move the problem
from one area to another.
And then by doing so, make
even loads of other problems.
I could be really crass.
I won't be.
I think good policy is
made by actually policy
makers, legal teams, designers,
developers all coming together
so that we can have a
shared knowledge of what
each other needs to do, so
we can help each other out.
I really do think that policy
is so linked to delivery.
That's the way that
good policy is made.
So no more privacy laws
or cookie banners, please.
It is, yeah.
CENNYDD BOWLES: I am
going to say no, there's
nothing you shouldn't touch.
You should have a look at.
Everything, nothing
should be off the table.
You have smart people.
You've got people from industry.
You got people from academia.
I'd trust you to
do the right thing.
I would say don't necessarily
assume that all the tech
industry is anti-regulation
or pro-self-regulation.
I wish I could
remember the source.
I'd have to look it up.
83% of people in
the general public
were in favor of increased
regulation of the tech
industry.
That figure was 93% if you
worked in the tech industry.
I'm in the 93%.
JOSH LOVEJOY: I would
just sort of maybe
ask for some nuance
maybe in certain areas,
or a lot of areas.
But one that comes to mind
on this privacy notion
is about how we can evaluate
the effectiveness and usefulness
of a machine learning model.
So there's a wide gap there.
And it does come into
having more practitioners
in the conversation.
Machine learning model is only
as good as its optimization
approach.
And the way that you know how to
figure out what that precision
recall measurement
looks like, is
by having a good ways to slice
the results of the model.
The only way you can slice
the results of the model
is by having data sets
that are intentionally
over representatives
of specific groups
that need to be cared for.
And so that question of
how do we care for people
and take care of
one another, we need
to know who we're
taking care of.
We have to have some
notion of identity.
And standard privacy leads us
in a direction of anonymity
and data blindness.
That's the default. And we have
to be conscientious about how
we deal with the
considerations for people
needing that right
to be forgotten
and that right to their
privacy, while also being
able to understand how we're
underperforming for groups that
will, by definition,
always be at the margins.
AUDIENCE: We have time
for a very last question.
KAREN KAUSHANSKY: I was just
going to say, building on that,
is let's make sure whoever
is steering and putting
to this process, cover a
lot of the diverse groups
that we have, as
well as making sure
that design is part of that.
Because I think we're
designing this for people.
And so very often it's
not just engineering
who should be driving that.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
It does work.
Thank you so much for
your helpful comments.
So this is just on the
question of explanation
on whether people
want them or not.
So I think people can
be owed to things, even
if they don't want them.
But the second
thing is with regard
to whether people do
want explanations.
We might think that in
some ways they don't
understand the stakes yet.
And that the reason that they
might not want information
is because they believe
that even if they have it,
they don't have control.
So they can't alter anything
about that situation.
I just wonder if that
might be a longer term
aspiration of this community
to move from explanation
to designing products
that actually give people
meaningful control
over their lives?
SARAH GOLD: Yes.
I really love that.
Everything about that
comment, I think was spot on.
When we've done work looking at
people's mental models of risk
in medical information--
[INAUDIBLE] now I can't
use that quote because It's
from a research session.
This is difficult talking
about some of this stuff.
Because you're like, oh!
That thing that you
can't say about that.
Which was that people don't
have a good idea of the risks
at stake, I think, at all.
That means it's
really hard for people
to care about
explanations of it.
So I think your
point is spot on.
JOSH LOVEJOY: I
think we also fall
into this trap of
trying to design AI
as some sort of
universal affordance.
You can to show up
to a blank screen,
and then just emote
at it or something.
And it'll just like, no what
you want, which is crazy.
And I had this experience
this morning that made that.
I like to sort of tie these
things into active decisions
that I have to make.
I was just walking
along the sidewalk.
And [INAUDIBLE] she gave
me the insight yesterday
that kids walk themselves
to school here.
It's amazing.
It's not at all how
it happens in America.
KAREN KAUSHANSKY:
At six-years-old.
JOSH LOVEJOY: It's unbelievable.
So this is sort of
pack of little kids
came at me with--
it wasn't a pack.
It was four.
--on little scooters.
And I was paralyzed,
because I was like, wait.
Which side of the road
am I supposed to walk on?
There was that moment
where I was like,
do I go pass on the
right or on the left?
I'm in Europe.
I don't know what to do.
And so I realized
at that moment I
was walking up to this
universal interface.
And I was dumbstruck.
And so I just stood still
and let the kids go past me.
And I feel very frequently when
we design UX for these systems,
we're expecting people to
just know how to use it.
We come up with skew
morphism and UI design
to deal with this.
We come up with a personality
and conversation design
to sort of try to give people
a sense of what to say at it.
But more often than not,
systems fail for people
or aren't thoughtful
about human need.
And so the reference points
that people bring to the table
are the thing is
probably going to fail.
So I'm not going
to try anything.
So I think one of
the things we can do
is get more specific
and design systems that
aren't AI, but are
just tools and products
and will use normal language.
And to get back to
the point about magic,
I think that a
success state when
we're talking about
generative systems
or adaptations or machine
learning that helps facilitate
a useful interaction,
and helps somebody just
feel like the self-efficacy
has been improved,
not the trust in the system.
So more precision in the
targeting and the design.
The use case is more focused.
Less about this let the
user sort of figure it out.
And then I think through that,
we can make it more tractable.
KAREN KAUSHANSKY: And if we do
that-- just to build on that--
if we also set the expectations
of what the system can do,
what it does really
well, then it
will better set the
expectations for the user
and we'll have more successes
instead of just more failure.
Because we've
trying things and it
really was never designed to do.
CENNYDD BOWLES: I agree
with the sentiment
that yes, we should
try and offer
people control of these systems.
But realistically,
not everyone will
have control over
their destinies
within social systems.
So where possible, yeah, sure.
We can try and challenge that.
We can try and
change that reality,
that experience for that user.
But I'm also wary of
offering false hope.
There are many things that exist
outside of our direct control.
And I think explainability and
not a shrug of the shoulders,
but a definite sort
of that's the way it's
going to be, I'm afraid,
mate, is sometimes going
to be the solution as well.
AUDIENCE: I don't know!
[LAUGHTER]
KAREN KAUSHANSKY:
Now we're going
to talk about
opportunities, right?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: There
is an opportunity
for drinks and heavy
appetizers about to happen.
Since that heavy appetizers
isn't a local Zurich punk band
that we've hired, it's
something we're going to eat.
But in terms of
opportunities, just
to editorialize one thing--
I think one thing to
your question, sir,
about things to bear in mind--
something that I like to bear
in mind, or at least
to keep myself sane--
is one of the things
that technology does
is it changes the structure of
things for good and for ill.
And I think that we shouldn't
approach the business models
for the use of
framings, the ways
we create products for the
next 20 years in the way
that we have the last 20 years.
We have new technologies
coming down the pike,
not just in terms of machine
learning and learning systems,
but also in terms of some of
the fundamentals of computing,
which are going to change the
topology of what we're doing.
And we can judo flip that
into societies we want,
or we can shrug and deal
with it in other ways.
So I think modeling the future
in ways that don't necessarily
reflect the language of the
past is something that designers
are quite good at.
So invites to some
of your meetings.
Thank you.
Um, beer and appetizers.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Before we go then, thank
you to our panelists.
AUDIENCE: Yes, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: And thank
you all for coming.
I think this was a
great opportunity to--
selfishly speaking-- to
empower the UX community
to be more intentional
and aware and enticed
to shape the ecology in
the way that we actually
wanted to impress society.
And I think as someone who
is very deep in product,
I really appreciated that.
So thank you so much.
This was great.
A huge thanks to [INAUDIBLE].
Where is [INAUDIBLE]?
Thank you so much, as usual.
Thanks to the Zurich
facilities and our sponsors,
both [? pair, ?] as well
as actually [INAUDIBLE],,
which is a user experience
team for our ads and payments
and these ugly things.
I'm just joking.
But this is really neat--
an intention to really
kind of create a discourse
and empower designers
and the researchers
to really think about how
we're shipping technologies
in our product.
And then, last but--